the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so what's been important the last couple
of lectures
Christina transfer function all right
how about something else
modal coordinates and I'll expand that
to call this modal analysis in general
anything else
anything while I think more about that
and are there any questions for the week
no what are anything muddy fuzzy not
quite clear to you that if I have time
to say a few words about today you'd
like me to talk about is that just like
so we did originally
his model analysis a an alternative way
of if the analogy isn't too helpful but
modal analysis is one way of attacking
the equations of motion that describe
vibration of linear systems you can work
through the entire analysis and figure
out the solution to the equations of
motion the unusual with these multiple
degree freedom vibration problems you
can cast them as a mass matrix times an
acceleration vector plus a stiffness
matrix times the displacement vector
equals some forcing function right so
these are and we linearize them and we
know they're for vibration problems we
can solve these equations using modal
analysis or we can solve them brute
force directly without breaking the the
results into their modal contributions
and so there really are two kind of
approaches that you can use to doing it
so they any other kind of questions yeah
just the ratio
the case is a two degree of freedom
system so mode shapes for mode n of an N
degree of freedom system like let's say
N equals three here so for mode in the
mode shape and we you have to you always
have to present some normalization I do
the normalization oftentimes by just
saying okay I'm going to make the top
cordon that I get to give it unit
amplitude so that's I'm going to take a
1 and divide it by itself and that will
give me a 1 and then every other ones
becomes a2 over a1 a3 over a1 the mode
shape says if this is then 1 minus 1/2
and 1/4 it says that if mo if coordinate
generalized coordinate 1 moves a unit
amount generalized coordinate 2 will
move half of that in its in the opposite
and it's negative in its negative
direction this could be an exodus
placement and that could be a rotation
but they all have positively defined
directions right so if there's a
positive one at x1
there's a minus 1/2 at generalized
coordinate 2 and there's no plus 1/4
generalized coordinate 3 and that ratio
stays constant for the mode and if so if
you have if it's an initial condition
problem have you set it up so that it
you actually give it an exhibit just an
initial displacement of exactly that
shape it will sit there and vibrate only
in that mode and you'll notice that it
will enact amping the proportion of the
first two the other two stays exactly
constant that's what a mode is and it's
a character it's a property of the
system the natural frequencies of
property and the Shea
type of every mode is a property of that
system okay anything else questions next
lecture we'll do more modal analysis we
did the response to initial conditions
yesterday Tuesday we'll talk about the
response to external forces and then we
give us a chance to review it and post
it on stellar last night I put up a
little two-page sheet that is a cookbook
how to do the procedure of modal
analysis it's a very cookbook you know
just step by step bang bang bang and
everything get everything falls out any
other questions yeah is that where you
get the mode shape by solving the
characteristic you're doing it by hand
by solving the characteristic equation
which we're going to get some practice
at today so I think this is the exercise
of today's how to get natural
frequencies and mode shapes as in a
graph it shows the displacement of it or
it shows the time history well sometimes
to do if it's easy you know like for a
vibrating string it's easy to draw the
mode shape and it is yeah went into a
vibrating string if first mode vibration
looks like half a sine wave the mode
shape is just half the sine way going up
and down in space for this system the
mode shape is to amp to different
amplitudes of these two bobs and their
relative motion we're going to figure
that out today okay we better get the
owner you won't finish so the good
questions and
here's the here's the system simplified
just into two Bob's and Masel strings
here's the equations of motion for that
linear they've been linearized already
there's no sine Thetas or anything and
if part of the linearization so you
enters this assumes then small
amplitudes right it not only did the
sine you know the torque for a pendulum
you get this MGL sine theta term and so
the linearization you say small angles
sine theta becomes theta so that gives
that's where this G over L sine theta is
become theta term there's another
assumption that's been made to model
this system we're essentially modeling
the system and that is for small angles
are assuming the spring rains horizontal
because if it the spring puts a force on
the rod right and what you wants the
torque about that point these two
equations are the equations for torque
about that point about that point and if
the the torque is the spring force times
that distance and if they're
perpendicular it's just that's just one
times the other but if it doesn't remain
perpendicular they need have to take a
cosine right and it gets really messy so
another part of this small angle
approximation is that spring stays
horizontal all right there's your
equation of motion and you can see
what's happened here is that this used
to have an m1 l1 squared that's the this
is the mass moment of inertia of that
mass we've divided through the equation
by m1 l1 squared and that's put things
in the bottom here like that then it
just makes this actually a little easier
to work with the mass matrix turns out
to be 1:1 when you do this but it's
still the same two equations of motion
I've just divided through by m1 l
squared and this one by m2 l squared so
these are your equations of motion and
your job is to come up first of all
let's just put them in matrix form and
you're going to do this in groups today
we've got
five 10 and 18 people so that's probably
four groups of four work together in
groups quickly let's put up the
equations of motion from this in matrix
form
yeah and then walk out to one piece
in your look in your lower left yeah
matrix is is the oh the cake what I'm
worried about the M oh there you go yeah
just one there's a single kick the only
one spring so we just call it cake okay
alright you're all looking pretty good
to me and the last hour we did this and
it went up and I looked at it and I just
had one of these moments of just Oh
cognitive dissonance it just says how
can that possibly be and the reason was
this stiffness matrix this matrix is not
diagonal not die scuse me I'm and wrong
word this matrix is not symmetric and
linear stiffness matrices are always
symmetric so I saw this as is what has
gone wrong every one of you had the same
answer every one of you the resistance
matrices are not symmetric it's minus K
1 over m 1 and minus K minus K over m 1
minus K over m 2 in it I did by had a
heart failure I've been doing this for
you know 40 years and it's always been
symmetric and almost said you guys
unanimously get asymmetric so I figured
it out
a great relief we divided through by m1
l1 squared in the first
and m2 l2 squared in the second equation
the stiffness matrix by just the true
stiffness matrix hasn't been divided
through by the ML Squared's and it is
indeed symmetric okay it's one of the
things that's really helpful to know
because when you're working these things
out if there's something you know the
symmetric you don't have to evaluate all
the terms you only have to do the
diagonals and a half of the ones the
mass matrices you use these symmetric to
there's maybe some exceptions if you
start putting in gyroscopes and stuff
like that but then it's not very linear
okay so your next task is to the way we
find we find natural frequencies mode
shapes kind of the hard way doing use
and algebra is to find the caret what we
call the characteristic equation alright
it turns out to be a fourth order
equation and make it to the fourth find
it don't solve it just write down the
acoustic equation for this thing that's
you're up then as soon as you have that
come up write it down to remember you
basically have matrices this is the what
you're working with you've got something
of this form we've normally divided
through by some stuff to collect terms
but how do you go about going from the
equations of motion to your algebraic
equation you know make it to the fourth
I want you to write up the edges want
you right up the characteristic equation
you're going to get a quadratic and
Omega to the fourth just we're open
write down the equation I expand what do
you mean well you send if I want an
equation a negative fourth just write it
just write one up there and if you want
to simplify the writing you can let H
equal oh and buy let's see you know I
forgot to tell you something the key
assumption here key thing is going to
make it easier for you let ya sorry my
mistake
let the m2 be equal then it makes it a
lot easier and then you can say call H G
over L plus K over m and it'll kind of
make the quote make the equation a whole
lot easier to write
right okay people are getting all the
same answers here that's so good okay so
the next step is I will give you you
solve this you get omega 1.is G over L
like 1 squared is G over L and a mega 2
squared is G over L plus 2 K over m
those are two natural frequencies so now
find the mode shapes find the mode
shapes if you know the natural
frequencies now you go back in and you
get a lift
pardon yeah keep H if I think H will
things will fall out rather quickly well
I like to zoo I like to normalize the
mode shapes so the top one is 1 and so
the top with the top element of the mode
shape vector I call a 1 or u1 down
through u N and so if you divide out
each one by the top one the top one
becomes 1 the second one becomes a2 over
a1 the third one of its three degree
freedom be a 3 over a1 when the fact
that this equal you know you just solve
this equation to get to get that
characteristic determinant you said this
was true and when that's a particular
kind of situation where you have linear
a set of linear homogeneous equations
equal to 0 they're not independent
remember from algebra when you have a
equations with constant coefficients and
you have no the they're equal to a
constant in the constants are all 0
means if they are not independent
equations so this is two equations and
two unknowns and they're not independent
you won't be able to solve for unique
values of a1 u1 and u2 you only be able
to get the ratio so you're solved
basically you found this value you're
going to plug in a value for Omega
squared and find out the values of a1
a tooth at work that's what the mode
shapes are let's let me pull you back
together here and let's run through this
kind of quickly you've basically solved
this equation you said I'm going to
assume this thing it has a mode shape
and a frequency you know a harmonic it's
going to vibrate son damn so it's either
you could write this as cosine Omega T
sine Omega T e to the I Omega T but it
has some constants out here called the
shape you plug it in to the you plug
that into the equations of motion you're
going to get big that you get back this
expression the two derivatives the theta
double dot to give you the minus Omega
square it's right you can write it like
that you can throw away the e to the I
Omega T in this case I've expanded this
mm is just that one one matrix so this
part looks like this the K matrix looks
like this you can add them element by
element so this is minus Omega squared
plus h minus K over m this one is minus
K over m and this term is minus Omega
squared plus h again right times u1 or
u2 the two elements that we're looking
for that's two equations into this is
just now an algebraic equation to
algebraic equations this times u1 minus
K over m times u2 and the second
equation is phat now we know there
there's only two equations and not
linearly independent so you actually
only have one useful equation if it's a
three by three you'd have they're not
independent but you need to use two out
of the three yeah
second one I take the first one and I
multiply it up here and that gives me an
equation this times u1 plus this times
u2 that's equation one I take this and I
multiply by that and I get minus K over
m u2 and this is u1
this is the Omega squared I plugged in
the natural frequencies that we saw for
right Oh minus Omega squared okay I'm
picking one of the natural frequencies G
over L so this is up here is G over L
plus h u1 my that one down here it's G
over L hu - and you see these two
equations turn out to be this year you
want to do it one at a time you just
plug in one of the natural frequencies
and you get two equations in two
unknowns and they're going to each give
you exactly the same information they're
not independent any longer so you solve
this one H it has what in it a plus G
over L and a plus K over m right
the G over L p-- is cancelled and you're
left with K over m u1 minus K over m u2
equals zero if this implies that u1
equals u - right
this is the G over L in this I'm going
to plug in the that is H I just put it
in here I've plugged in one of the
natural frequency squared the G over L
ports cancel this is plus K over mu 1
minus K over mu 2 that means K over m u
1 equals K over mu to cancel out the K
over m I get that it just tells me that
that's the answer and I'm if that's the
answer the vector looks like u1 u2
that's also equal to factor out of U 1 u
1 times 1 + u2 over u1 that's that's the
mode shape there 1 + u2 over u1 that's
how you factor it out to put it in the
normalized form you just take whatever's
in the top one and divide everything in
the column by it so to do the second
equation you just now go back to this
plug in for Omega 2 squared the second
natural frequency is G over L plus 2 K
over m this is G over L minus K over m
the K over m s cancel and you just left
with G over L you work this through
you're going to find out that u 2 equals
minus u1 if you put in the second one
yeah
so we have a 1 over 80 group you want to
be so obviously
but I don't understand you just like
plug back into you then you sit like you
want over you do people do whatever you
do well when you solve this you find
that K over m u1 equals K over m u2
right that's just saying in this case
they are equal period that's and that's
all you learn you only have two
equations and they're not independence
of means you only have one equation and
you don't learn you're not able to solve
for numeric values of u1 and u2 at best
you can get u 1 over u 2 right so you
can in fact you can just solve this for
u u2 over u1 and it would be 1 ok well
that's my back in my vector format I
want to write the mode shape as a vector
you've solved for you one for you one so
you could actually do this you can take
you know that that's true you say well
top ones one and the bottom one is the
same as that so the mode shape remote
one is that if you want to do one
the ratio of two more days there's a I'm
using use and some of their use days
they're the elements of the mochit
vector okay so we had put in the other
natural frequency instead of I'm am just
drawn too many steps here at once to so
our first equation looks like minus
Omega squared plus h minus K K over m
and the second equation is minus K over
m and over here is minus Omega squared
plus h again that's our matrix when we
add these two matrices together the
minus Omega squared M plus K that's what
it looks like when you add the elements
together right
and we're looking these are two
equations and two unknowns we're looking
for the answer for some u1 u2 multiplied
by this so you multiply this out you get
minus Omega squared plus h u1 minus K
over m u2 and now let's plug in the
second natural frequency so mega two
squared is that and solve for the second
mode now plug it in here we get minus G
over L minus two K over m plus h which
is G over L plus K over m plus and
that's times u1 plus K over m u2 right
all that's equal to zero
this cancels this this this plus one
minus two I get a minus K over m out of
this so I have this whole thing gives me
minus K over mu 1 plus K over m u 2
which should i agree with you where did
I make the mistake oh good all right and
this is equal to 0 k over m is cancel
out and you find that this implies that
u 1 equals minus u 2 and so the mode
shape for two for mode two you could
write as u 1 and u 2 is minus u 1 if you
will and it's obvious if you factor out
u 1 you get u 1 and a 1 minus 1 right so
now you've solved through the second
mode shape if this had been more than a
two by two like a three by three degree
freedom system you would get 2 you'd
have to use two of the three equations
to get the ratio you'd get two equations
in three unknowns and at best you can
find the two of them in terms of the
third and the third one would be u 1 you
just divide out all the others by u 1 so
you want to get their ratios okay so
those are the those are the natural
frequencies those are the mode shapes
let's demonstrate it let's look at it
this is basically the system and you now
know that mode shapes are 1 & 2 mode
shapes of this thing are 1 1 for the
first mode and 1 minus 1 for the second
mode
and the modal expansion theorem depends
on this this fact that the mode shapes
form a complete independent set of
vectors that are orthogonal to one
another a weighted sum of all the mode
shapes of the system can represent any
allowable motion of the system any
possible motion system can be written as
a weight of so anyway I can displace
this thing these things a little bit
here a little bit there I can write that
position as a weighted sum of those two
mode shapes so that lets say I want to
have initial conditions on displacement
our theta 1 0 and theta 2 0 no initial
velocity is just initial angles and I
want that initial condition vector to be
1 0 I'm claiming I can write that as a
sum of something 1 1 plus another or
something 1 minus 1 so what does c1 and
c2 have to be to give me that you ought
to be able to kind of do that by
inspection almost
like for example just try them equal in
what happens
so happening here right great so this to
satisfy this it's a half 1 1 plus a half
1 minus 1 and they're just illustrated
the fact that you can represent an
arbitrary deflection allowable
deflection of the system as a weighted
sum of the two mode shapes all right so
that says if we if I make the initial
now this says that theta 1 is 1 and
theta 2 is 0 what is telling us is by
modal analysis that means the resulting
motion should look like the response to
initial conditions where I have equal
amounts of each of those two modes so
there ought to be some vibration at
Omega 1 now out of these equal amount of
vibration at Omega 2 agreed ok let's try
it
I'll hold one of these in place I'll
deflect the other one and let go
now that one's stationary and this one's
moving and a few cycles later this one
will be stationary and that one will be
moving so are what you observing could
that motion what you're seeing possibly
be a mode a natural mode by itself no
because the different proportions are
changing right this is the sum of two
modes exactly as you said equal amounts
of each and when you do that you have
two things
each two things of equal amplitude -
cosine Omega T like terms of equal
amplitude and different frequencies you
get a phenomena known as beating that's
what this is beating means it one
vibrates and then will get small and
then you'll see it build up again and it
gets small so if you watch eating one of
these it's doing large and stopping and
the other one is doing the same thing
but actually ninety degrees out of phase
so what we're really saying is that the
motion of this system this is one one
half and one one cosine Omega 1 T plus
1/2 one minus 1 cosine Omega 2 T that's
the total responsibility let's look at
the first line of this this says 1/2
cosine Omega 1 T plus 1/2 cosine Omega 2
T should be equal to the motion we call
theta 1 of T that's the first row here
this is theta 1 theta 2 so the first row
of this the first equation is that and
to equal amplitude cosines of different
frequencies you can write as cosine
Omega 2 minus Omega 1
over two times T times cosine Omega 1
plus Omega 2 over 2t this beat phenomena
that you're seeing when you when you'd
plot this and you this is now for theta
1 it'd start us off at some amplitude
and the actual motion you see if you
will if you watch it it does what my
going what I'm drawing right now this
envelope is this term the difference
frequency you divided by 2
what's inside is that term and this is
called this is called beating this is
the equation for beating when you add to
equal amplitude cosines together they
give you something looks like that in
one period of the beat is how long it
takes to go through one full cycle from
here to here that's one period of the
beat yeah
wow that's just trig identity you add
you just go back to your trig take
cosine of a plus cosine of B you'll find
out you can do that I'm not going to
don't have time to grunt to go through
that and the other one is 1/2 cosine
Omega 1t minus 1/2 cosine Omega 2t and
that turns out to be sine Omega 2 minus
Omega 1 over 2t times sine Omega 1 plus
Omega 2 over 2 quantity times time and
that means that the theta 2 coordinate
what it looks like when you draw it is
90 degrees how to face it's the same
thing but it starts at 0 here and beats
but it starts 0 where that one started
here and that's what you look at 1 so
that's theta 1 and this is Theta 2 when
one of them stops and that's one of
these lines one of these equations and
the other equation is 90 degrees so that
one's stopped right now 90 if PI over 2
later this one will be stopped so the
beat it's behaves like sine in one case
and behaves like cosine in the other
case one of these needs a minus sign
that's plus minus and plus minus and
plus
that's what if you have unequal amounts
if you we have exactly equal amounts of
of the two modes if you have unequal
amounts of the two modes then it's not
going to be a half and a half whatever
it's like one and point one then do you
see full beats does one come to a stop
if they're not equal you'll find that
the two sums of the two motions will
look the envelope will look like this
it'll be modulated each one's motion to
look like that it'll never go to 0 coy
okay that's beating no time we're good
and let's see did we do if we said the
one natural one natural mode is the two
opposite one another so if I start go
equal amounts in opposite directions and
let go it ought to just sit there and
vibrate all day like that
no beats because it's it is the one zero
case over there so this is a zero one
case this is one minus one I gave an
initial displacement in exactly the
shape of the second mode and that means
the two contributions are that one of
those constants is zero it's there's no
mode one in this it's only mode two and
they'll sit here all day long and by
right just in the mode two and if i
displace it in the shape of mode one
only it will vibrate and that's hard to
do because i have to ask to have to move
exactly the same amount that's mode one
and it should by rate all day long and
mode one because now there's no mode two
involved in that one you can see it's
already getting a little out of phase
like it's hard to get it for me to move
my hands exactly the same amount so I
have a little bit of both the other mode
in there but you'll never see either one
of these come to a full stop it's
actually doing that
when you get a little contamination to
the second mode in there all right
okay so I've posted on stellar a little
two-page sheet that just gives you step
by step how to do a modal analysis it's
just cookbook modal houses is easy you
do it all on the computer just put in
your M matrix and your K matrix and you
crank stuff out next Tuesday we did
modal analysis yesterday just from
initial conditions next Tuesday would do
modal analysis assuming you've got
harmonic excitation and steady-state
vibration and do that kind of thing